also ich finds halt schade dass
13-jährige sich sowas gerne wünschen bzw
sowas machen und dann online stellen
stellt euch mal vor ihre eltern sehen
dass er überhaupt glaubt jetzt
willkommen beim ein video natürlich
erstmal so eigentlich wollte ich mit
videos jetzt wieder durchziehen die
letzten fünf tage ist wider wechsel
kommen tut mir leid aber ich war richtig
viel unterwegs habe richtig coole sachen
erlebt deswegen ging es leider irgendwie
nicht allerdings kommt heute ein video
morgen in video und sowie das erst mal
weiter so jetzt kommt auch viele videos
verspreche ich euch wirklich und ja ich
will gar nicht lange lagern gefangen mit
dem heutigen thema an
das ist wirklich schon videos habe ich
schon länger in planung weil ich mir
dabei so gedacht habt vor drei vier
wochen schon einig darüber kann zeigen
ich mein video machen weil es gibt
nämlich mal wieder um unsere wunderbare
jugend klar ist für mich selber
natürlich auch noch als jugendliche
eigentlich dazu warum sollte ich das
nicht tun bin ich ja auch noch so so
mehr so die etwas jüngeren allerdings
ich weiß auch ich habe viele junge
zuschauer ich meine ich damit garantiert
nicht ich meine vielleicht von euch
0,000 000 000 1 prozent oder so also
wirklich aber da gibt es wirklich diese
leute wo ich mir denke bzw
diese 12 13 14 jährigen leute wieso man
ist ihr seid noch so jungen macht andere
sachen oder es stellt und stellt euch
mal vor eure eltern sehen dass ich will
jetzt auch eigentlich direkt auf den
punkt kommen und zwar war ich oder mit
der zeit ich bin natürlich sehr
finsteren unterwegs ins zu haben
freilich auch mega christian geben folgt
mit da wenn jetzt noch nicht tut und auf
jeden fall finde ich in letzter zeit
immer mehr von solchen profilen ich habe
jetzt heute einfach mal schnell als
rausgesucht und ein screenshot gemacht
und zwar sie dieses profil so aus ich
habe möglichst vieles zensiert aber es
sieht immer noch schlimm ausfindig und
diese ganze häufung von diesen instagram
profilen von irgendwelchen zwölf oder 13
jährigen kindern hat mich jetzt dazu
veranlasst ihre beiden video zu machen
und einfach mal meine meinung dazu zu
sagen weil ich weiß nicht ich finde das
irgendwie schlecht sondern entwicklung
ja an sich so das profil ist also
fragwürdig ich lese mal kurz vor
manchmal ist das leben ein verdammter
[ __ ] und spielt mit dir aber dann
musst du halt besser spielen ist ein
satz der für eine 13-jährige vielleicht
auch etwas fragwürdig erscheinen mag
dieser satz den will ich allerdings erst
mal außen vor lassen wir halten jetzt
erstmal unser blickfeld auf das
profilbild und solche profilbilder die
die fallen mir in letzter zeit wirklich
so oft auf ne gebt euch das mal ich weiß
nicht ob das diese 13-jährige ist oder
ob sie sich gerne so etwas wünscht aber
das ist doch krank das sind knutschfleck
am hals oder am kinn keine ahnung wo
auch immer 12 34 55 bibelfeste cluj
flecke erstens das ist doch scheiße aus
und da stelle ich mir in letzter zeit
wirklich immer mehr die frage wie kommt
man dazu so ein bild der reis zu stellen
ich meine klar es gibt auf der einen
seite gibt es mädchen die sind 13 jahre
alt wie die auch die war ja 13 13 jahre
mit 16 war das auch komisch aber mit 13
ist es natürlich noch komischer dann
geht es erst mal diese mädchen so die
haben vielleicht wirklich ein jungen
kennengelernt in dem es spaß macht ihr
halt weiß ich nicht zwei stunden am hals
zu saugen damit so ein will zustande
kommt auf der anderen seite gibt es dann
auch die 13 jährigen die sich
anscheinend wirklich so sowas gerne
wünschen oder sowas hier zu haben ich
meinen ganz ehrlich das ist überhaupt
kein natürlicher vorgang so was zu haben
da muss man schon
ich kann das mal kurz nach stellt so
will kann man kurz wieder weg dankeschön
so auf jeden fall das hier ist wie vor
16 einen playstation 4 spielt mit dem
ich jetzt kurz in einer beziehung bin
und dieses spiel möchte mir jetzt was
mache ich gerade alter.de ganz ehrlich
dieses spiel wäre das jetzt ein mensch
müsste mir locker eine stunde am hals
saugen dazu was überhaupt zustande kommt
ich stelle mir das gerade so vor wie
machen diese 13
keine ahnung ich will das jetzt nicht
darstellen auf jeden fall das ist halt
wirklich total weiß nicht selbst wenn
jetzt will ich auch nicht zu sehr ins
detail gehen
es kann natürlich wirklich sein das ist
zwar irgendwie heute auf jeden fall kann
es sein dass vor einer bestimmten
aktivität ja sowas zustande kommt das
vielleicht so ein kleiner knutschfleck
entsteht aber das alles andere
das ist das ist nicht menschlich das ist
einfach das ist für mich ist das
irgendwie krank zu ich finds halt schade
dass 13-jährige sich sowas gerne
wünschen bzw sowas machen und dann
online stellen stellt euch mal vor eure
eltern sehen das so gut das war einer
der gründe warum ich dieses video
gemacht habe und ich habe wirklich
gestern oder so keine ahnung irgendein
bild auf meiner timeline startseite bei
facebook gehabt da dachte ich auch er
jetzt ist komplett vorbei oder ja ich
habe nämlich dieses bild hier gesehen
warum darüber steht bei vonns das ding
ist so ich würde eigentlich gar nicht
sagen nur das foto hat fast tausend
vielleicht wird da beide schon über 1000
es keine ahnung das heißt 1000 gleich
ein ganzes 1000 leute wollen das alter
leute ganz ehrlich für mich ist das
nicht natürlich menschliches sondern
ganz klar körperverletzung und wenn dann
unter den teig an irgendwelche zwölf
oder 13 jährigen mädchen sind das stelle
ich mir echt die frage was ist bei euch
nicht so richtig halte ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht ob das berechtigt ist
hier über ein video zu machen oder ob
ich keine ahnung ich finds halt
irgendwie ein bisschen falsch so dass 12
oder 13 jährige mädchen so was von schön
finde ich finde dass es komisch dass man
sich so etwas wünscht das ist halt echt
ich finds halt irgendwie krank so ganz
ehrlich ist so ich weiß nicht wie ihr
seht also wenn ihr mir da zustimmen so
dann lasst auf jeden fall mal daumen
nach oben da oder schreibt sie die
kommentare keine ahnung allerdings ja
die jugend von heute steht auf
körperverletzung beziehungsweise dass
man sich gegenseitig zwei stunden am
körper saugt und das eventuell auch
schon mit zwölf oder 13
alles klar da hatte ich andere
interessen aber wenns tristan ist das so
ich hoffe dass wieder aufgefallen weil
es ja dann lasst auf jeden fall jetzt
noch unklar morgen kommt auch ein
richtig cooles video deswegen morgen
kommt das um 16 uhr schon online also
morgen 16 uhr einschalten snapserver
weil es ein gemälde können wir gerne
folgen aber nicht vergessen hat rainer
wirth schaue ich geh jetzt mal draußen
weil das wetter ist echt super und kein
bock mehr drin zu hoffen trug